yeah didn't I tell you there are a lot
of videos for me to do there are a lot
of videos for me to do I know this news
is like a week old I wasn't even going
to do a video on this until I realized
the last video I did on this subject was
me going Ben Affleck as Batman
I don't really know Jesse Eisenberg's
gonna suck and gal the DOS bad choice my
opinion on Ben Affleck as Batman was
they might pull it off I just don't see
it and in a world we're seeing is
believing that is Batman maybe I'm being
too fickle maybe I'm too easy to jump to
the other side I'm just saying in terms
of looks dude looks like Batman
any show that to my friend my friend was
like this bad giving credit to
Ben Affleck and his acting ability to
pull off Bruce Wayne and Batman that's
actually a pretty solid picture but
that's not all we got a comic-con a week
ago also as that kid was tardy to class
so it just makes sense that I would be
bringing you this news a week after it
was relevant it was actually a comic-con
trailer of sorts I didn't I didn't see
it at Comic Con new outline for Hall H
no thank you I didn't stand in any lines
I just walked around like I said I met
fans and that was awesome if I'm
standing in line for cool like this
Batman V Superman stuff that I'm not
meeting you good people however it was
leaked on last nowhere now but this
footage was actually really cool it's
like Batman at the bat-signal and his
outfit he's wearing is straight-up Dark
Knight Returns and Superman's up there
in the sky looks dead - his eyes are
burning red like he's gonna toast his
face off it's pretty much what it is but
it was so cool to see because you know
last year at Comic Con the roller ah
this quote from The Dark Knight Returns
you're like a holy it's gonna be
like the Dark Knight Returns and then
this other news comes out of all these
CEOs or a shoehorn into this movie and
you're like is it really gonna be like
the Dark Knight Returns are you just
saying that to get people jacked up for
a movie that's gonna be overly inflated
but this outfit is straight-up from The
Dark Knight Returns so it makes me go
darn you - you're gonna fight which is
really cool they didn't use the Dark
Knight Returns thing as a sales tax well
they did but they used it as more than
the sales tax they're actually gonna
follow through with it like the title
Donna Justice is a spoiler at that point
pretty much you're telling me from the
title neither of them are gonna die and
they're both gonna mend ways and become
the Justice League by the end of this
movie extension there's no tension as
what happens when you do these YouTube
videos for too long you start picking
things apart that everyone looks at you
all your friends were like hey thanks
for taking all the excitement out of it
dick yeah there was a gal gadot as
Wonder Woman picture that was released
also and that one yeah she looks fine my
concern is not who looks my concern is
her acting ability I have no idea how
that's going to go to bed
have like I can be like okay if you look
the part I'm pretty sure you could
actually fill in the part is you're an
actor gal gadot is the model I'm not
sold on her yet Jesse Eisenberg that
shit's gonna be weird to me until I
actually see it on screen even then I
might come back to you reviewing the
movie going yeah that was weird to
me point is Batman V Superman V Aquaman
V everyone else the dawn of Justice I'm
more excited for like he is pretty much
the thing where I'm like you need to
sell me on Ben Affleck as Batman then I
can get excited for the movie the dude
walks the walk now that's for sure but
can he talk to Todd I actually heard
when I was at Comic Con about a picture
that was Ben Affleck and he had gray
hair because we haven't seen him as
Bruce Wayne yet picture with him as gray
hair people were like holy I think
that's him onset of Donna justice he's
like old and even if that's
it made me in my mind's eye go
holy he actually could be old
Batman you could be old Bruce Wayne that
mixed with that side profile picture
mixed with the armor from the Dark
Knight Returns and that trailer that was
shown in Hall age I guess me more
excited for it I figured I should update
you on the fact cuz the last you guys
have heard I was like Ben Affleck yeah
well we'll see I'm still saying we'll
see I'm just saying yeah it's kind of
cool I want them to fight I want Batman
to have his hands on kal-el's throat I
want him to say the lines word-for-word
about him being the one who beat him you
give me that along with loads every
word right Batman V Superman v Aquaman v
Wonder Woman have you seen that Comic
Con trailer have you seen it what did
you think about it if you've only seen
the pictures what do you think of Ben
Affleck as Batman now whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you wanna see more click right here to
see more